So in our case of eye color, where we have a brown allele and a bue allele, it
turns out that our brown allele is dominant over our blue allele. And what this
means is that it masks the effect of the blue allele so that you can't see it.
Alternatively, the blue allele is referred to as recessive, because it's effect
is masked when there is a dominant allele present. And we can show that here by
putting the blue allele inside the brown allele. Whereas the end product is we
can only see the result of the dominant allele. So, in this case, what color
eyes do you think the offspring would have?
&gt;&gt; Brown, since brown is the dominant allele.
&gt;&gt; Exactly.